today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
we have so much uh to cover today that i
will not
waste any time as i normally do a lot of
time wasting
normally on this program but not today
uh so we have
trump events and biden harris events to
talk about we'll start with trump donald
trump yesterday
uh very suddenly scheduling a press
briefing uh
right at the time that joe biden and
kamal harris were having their first
joint event which i will cover
momentarily
donald trump sounding very much the same
yesterday
as in previous press briefings not only
repeating some of the same things he
said previously but even repeating the
same stuff two three even four times
during yesterday's press briefing which
was
weird um we were it
the it actually went so poorly that fox
news even cut away from it
to instead discuss the biden harris
event if you can believe that but we
will get to that
and it does seem like donald trump was
motivated yesterday in
this late scheduled event at least
partially by trying to take attention
away from the biden harris event which
got
much more attention and much larger
viewership
um it was bad from the start donald
trump sounded particularly
slowed down sort of that's an ambulant
trump sleepwalking sleep talking lowest
energy that i've seen from him take a
look
and good evening as we continue to
confront the
china virus we're rebuilding america's
economy like
nobody thought possible actually we're
doing incredibly well stock markets up
almost 300 points again today
while our economy is performing
significantly better than
europe which people have to understand
very
strongly it's performing better than any
market anywhere in the world actually
at the same time europe has experienced
a forty percent higher excess mortality
than the united states so that's what i
call
uh casual xenophobic sin ambulant
trump you'll notice that everything now
is percentages
relative to the second quarter if you
watch this program
i warned you about this after historic
declines and horrible numbers in
second quarter we expected that
now we would start hearing about
relative to the second quarter
this has grown so much that has grown so
much
i won't you're all now briefed on that
because i've been talking about it and
warning you about it for months so i
don't
think i need to spend too much time on
that donald trump
still pushing this idea yesterday that
the election will be a fraud and
even mixing it here with obama gate
obamacare of course is this
greatest crime in history
that trump has claimed barack obama
committed we never actually find out
which laws were broken what is the
treason you claim is there
but it doesn't matter it's all being
wrapped up now the greatest fraud
ever perpetrated other than perhaps what
they did to my campaign
where they spied on my campaign
president obama biden and everybody else
and they got caught let's see what
happens this will be one of the greatest
frauds in history
so they're admitting that they want 3.5
billion
and they're not going to do
a deal that's good for the american
people sadly this is working and that's
why i think we need to keep talking
about this yes so
fraud all right whatever it's trump
again but it actually has convinced
two-thirds of republicans 65 percent to
be more precise
that the election may not be fair in
november
this is a strategy and we talked about
it yesterday trump's fixated on it for a
reason and it's because it's good for
him
to continue harping on the election is
not going to be fair the election is
going to be rigged
the election is going to be a fraud now
trump eventually took questions and he
did take more questions than the
previous day when i think he took
five mostly friendly questions and then
sort of skulked off the stage
trump did take questions yesterday he
got a good question about the
coronavirus death toll
donald trump keeps talking about how
cases don't tell us much
because cases are merely an artifact of
testing and because we test so much
as trump says cases don't really tell us
how we compare to other countries
reporter
astutely says well but our death toll is
a nightmare
uh in in absolute terms and in per
capita terms
and trump just deflects and insists on
talking about
cases instead mr president
one is is about you had
graphs about the economics of the topic
but deaths in america are still going up
whereas in europe
right now zero deaths in uk zero deaths
in france
what's going up by cases if you look at
cases and the cases are going up because
we do so much testing and we find it
and i call it fake media gold because we
do so much more testing than any other
country and when you do all that testing
you find cases go ahead steve real fast
so later i'm going to be covering
the biden harris event from yesterday
and you will no doubt notice
that the biden harris event was on
topic and coherent and
substantive whereas with donald trump
it's deflection and non-answers and
redirections and this actually at one
point got really interesting because fox
news reporter john roberts
asked the key question about trump's
idea for cutting the payroll tax which
he's been floating recently
you probably know if you watched my i
guess it was the
monday tuesday show that the payroll tax
funds
social security so if you permanently
cut the payroll tax
like trump claims he wants to do you
immediately have a funding issue for
social security a funding issue that you
create nonetheless
donald trump not shockingly when asked
about this is completely incoherent if
if you
permanently rescind the payroll tax how
do you pay for social security
we're taking it out of the general fund
and what we'll do
what we'll be doing is if we do that
we'll get it approved in that case by
congress
and we'll take the money from other
places other than we will not take it
from social security
in any way shape or form how do you fund
from the general fund when the general
fund
just incurred a debt of 2.8 trillion
dollars right we're gonna have
tremendous growth
we have tremendous growth you take a
look at what's happening here
next year unless somebody comes in who
doesn't know what they're doing and they
start raising taxes and forcing
everybody to leave the country or
leave their jobs and companies to close
we will have tremendous growth you will
see growth like you haven't seen in a
long time
okay this one he's actually been
claiming
since being a candidate anytime trump
has a policy
that makes no sense from the standpoint
of arithmetic trump says
it might seem like it removes money and
causes a financial shortfall but it
doesn't
because it's going to be so stimulative
that all of this new growth will show up
and the government is going to take in
more money it's simply not happened i
mean
the concept of it is the concept of
demand side stimulus
if you make the right moves from a
financial
standpoint in the economy you
generate growth which creates new
government revenue it didn't happen with
trump's tax cuts
it certainly wouldn't happen when you
cut the pay cutting the payroll tax
which funds social security
will not generate growth such that then
you get even more money from social
security elsewhere this is a shadow
campaign
if it were to succeed to hurt social
security
uh despite claims that it's biden who
will hurt social security
if trump were able to permanently cut
the payroll tax
that would really damage social security
i talked about it in detail
again it was monday or tuesday so i
won't do the the full
analysis again then we get into some
so-called fun
stuff if the term can really apply to
horror show
press briefings take a look at this
feeling that on november
4th somebody's going to announce schools
are open
the country's open everything's open i
really believe a lot of it's done for
political reasons
who want to know the truth i think so
but you're right
online is not the same as being in the
classroom he
really seems to think that the entire
coronavirus response in the united
states
is about him and him alone no one is
going to say on november 4th if the news
on november 4th is biden
defeated trump no one is going to say
open up all the schools because it was
safe all along the only way november 4th
will see
schools opened is if on november 3rd
cases go down 95 percent
the idea that this is all about trump is
just part of his narcissism
part of his delusions of grandeur and
it's a complete and total fantasy
compared with ebola where two people
died in 2014
the day of the midterms in november of
2014
ebola criticisms of obama stopped
you can even look at trump's own tweets
leading even in october of 2014
trump was hammering obama on ebola where
two people died
and after the midterms you never heard
about it again essentially
um this was yesterday maybe the most
slowed down
trump that we've ever seen check out
these pauses and of course
without the even without the pauses what
trump is saying here would make no sense
when you sit at home in a basement
looking at a computer your brain starts
to wither away
we have a lot of good experience at that
just by taking a look at what's
happening in politics
studies estimate that school closures
last
spring caused the average student to
fall 50
behind in math and roughly 35
i mean just just disjointed incoherent
and then the wild and wacky trump
falling apart refers to doctors as
doctors which is something else
altogether of course and really
continuing to struggle to speak
the doctors also warned about the risk
of increased abuse
then trump completely unable to say
fatalities multiple times he says
fatalities
and again he has this look on his face
where it's almost like one part of his
brain
realizes that the other part is saying
something that doesn't make sense
it's like when he said we need to know
the oranges the citrus fruit the oranges
of the investigation
he had to look like he knew there was a
malfunction
couldn't get control of it very very
similar here with fatalities
it's 99.995 percent of all fatalities
are adults think of that 99.95
that is extremely close to 100 percent
of all fatalities are
adults children look at you know
yosemite's
plasma fatilities just over the last
week
uh come on guys this isn't normal
something is wrong here and then the
last thing before i talk about how fox
news handled this briefing trump quickly
called on the right-wing propaganda
network
oan the question was a complete
non-sequitur about
some antifa website redirecting to joe
biden's website
it was just a set up for trump to link
biden and antifa when there is no such
link
i'm not even going to play the question
for you i don't want to give oan any air
time but right after oan
said what about this antifa website that
redirects to joe biden's website
um fox news put up on a lower third
graphic
trump says biden should denounce antifa
and this is how propaganda is generated
there is no antifa biden story
at all oan creates
such a discussion by asking a ridiculous
question
and next thing you know fox news has a
quote up on the screen
about what trump says biden should do
about antifa
last thing this is really interesting
even fox news had to cut away
when donald trump started ranting about
bill de blasio and
dog whistles about violence in chicago
and the like
fox cut away and said watch the rest on
our website if you want
it's not even believable what's
happening in chicago where
one weekend you have 78 people shot and
18
die in a weekend
and then successive weekends you have so
much of that happening
and it's it's not even it's really not
even believable
and if you let democrats run this
country and we've stopped it from going
other places if you let democrats run
this country
you'll have all of your cities be just
like that
thank you mr president the heads of the
boston and
good evening welcome to washington i'm
brad bear president trump holding his
daily briefing there we have it
streaming on foxnews.com you can see the
rest of it
uh he started by talking about the
success of the stock market in recent
days
what he calls a v-shaped recovery from
the coronavirus shutdown the president
also promising that checks
so fox news sing no more for us
and then very last thing i've said
during my live streams of these events
that donald trump repeats a lot of the
same
things he's been repeating verbatim the
same talking points on the virus since
april or may
it's almost like we haven't had months
in between and
160 000 deaths the recount put this
together and it is actually
literally verbatim true that trump is
just repeating the same stuff the united
states has now conducted more than
66 million tests that's far more than
any other than any country in the world
america has the largest at-risk
population 1.5 million residents of
nursing homes about five times about
five times that of other european
countries
we're on track to rapidly produce 100
million doses as soon as the vaccine is
vaccinated
we've delivered over 1 800 rapid point
of care
to nursing homes so this is all very
weird and we had a contrast yesterday of
the alternative
which was a biden harris event their
first event together
which is what i want to talk about next
so yesterday we had
the first joint event of the biden
harris ticket with kamala harris of
course
joining joe biden on the ticket the day
before yesterday
i covered this event live on youtube
twitch and facebook and i have to tell
you
the event was remarkable in how
unremarkably normal it was and when
things haven't been normal for a long
time that actually
sort of makes an impression on you and
what i mean by that is joe biden and
kamala harris
were able to stay on topic
put together a simple coherent narrative
about
why we should vote for them rather than
trump pence they spoke in complete
sentences
finished thoughts and it sounds like a
very low bar
because it is but that's what's wild
about it a whole bunch of stuff is now
unusual
because of the last three and a half
years of donald trump super interesting
by the way that the viewership for this
event was many times higher
than the viewership for trump's press
briefing which was scheduled at
essentially the same time and
you know there might be some novelty
element biden harris out on the campaign
trail is a new thing and maybe that's
generating interest
but there was this sense of hey this is
kind of normal
and we like it let's look at a few clips
here is joe biden introducing kamala
harris and using this terminology of
whining
which is interesting because when trump
first spoke about harris on tuesday
during the press briefing i said
he's just whining about her and that's
exactly the same language joe biden used
yesterday
you all knew was coming you could have
set your watches to it
donald trump has already started his
attacks
calling kamala quote nasty
whining about how she is quote mean
to his appointees it's no surprise
because whining is what donald trump
does best better than any president
american history
is anyone surprised donald trump has a
problem with a strong woman or strong
women across the board
then kamala harris speaking and speaking
quite compellingly
uh going right after trump and in
watching this it is really difficult to
imagine how mike
pence does well against kamala harris in
a debate
trump is also the reason millions of
americans are now
unemployed he inherited the longest
economic expansion in history
from barack obama and joe biden
and then like everything else he
inherited
he ran it straight into the ground
because of trump's failures of
leadership our economy has taken one of
the biggest hits
out of all the major industrialized
nations
with an unemployment rate that has
tripled
as of today this is what happens when we
elect a guy
who just isn't up for the job and then
here is kamala harris focusing right in
on coronavirus which i think is smart i
mean when you when you look at polling
coronavirus is one of the top issues on
which trump is most upside down where
people think he has failed
and coronavirus is regularly in the top
two issues for what matters most to the
country right now
so i believe this is the right way to
hit donald trump
when other countries are following the
science trump pushed
miracle cures he saw on fox news
while other countries were flattening
the curve he said the vice would just
poof go away quote like a miracle
so when other countries opened back up
for business
what did we do we had to shut down
again this virus
has impacted almost every
country but there's a reason it has
hit america worse than any other
advanced
nation it's because of trump's
failure to take it seriously
from the start so here's my thought even
if you don't like kamala harris
in terms of her politics if she is to
your right as she is with me
the energy she's bringing is much needed
and it's a noted
counterpoint to trump pence and in fact
it appears
that that's exactly how polls
show people reacting harris of the four
trump pence biden harris harris is the
only one polling with net favorability
meaning favorability exceeds people who
view her
unfavorably and this is an early sign
that from a strategic standpoint
strategic
this may have been a very good pick it
all remains to be seen
next week we'll have the dnc the next
week after that we will have the rnc
then we will be close to debates and so
it's going to be i mean listen
this is the election we're weeks away
it's going to be a very busy couple of
months and we're going to be with you
for the entire thing and
august 23rd will be the 15-year
anniversary of the david pakman show
we'll be running a beautiful possibly
illegal
membership special and i encourage you
to get on our newsletter at
davidpakman.com you'll get an email on
the 23rd telling you how to take
advantage of this
it's just a crazy crazy membership
discount the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinkist
and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great stephen hawking this is a book
that i have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are jeff
hellewell
and also a viewer who goes by the name
enigmatic
ecstasy uh there's probably
some interesting backstory there thanks
to both of you for supporting the
program
also big thank you to matthew schlegel
who's today's
long time sustaining member of the day
matt has been
a member for a long time and
a little inside story matt actually
helped the david pakman show acquire one
of our first
tricasters which was a big part of
improving the show very early on so matt
today's
long time sustaining member of the day
joined these great people by grabbing a
membership
at join joinpakman.com okay we now have
the first major election forecast for
biden versus trump in november and it
tells us
exactly what i told you last week which
is that donald trump can
easily win this election i'm talking
about the 538 forecast which sort of
synthesizes all the polling information
at the national and state level combines
it with historical data combines it with
other factors it's all analyzed
and out comes a number that tells us how
likely is it that trump will win
and how likely is it that joe biden will
win and these numbers
are then up to us to interpret in this
case the numbers are
that 538 gives joe biden a 71
chance of winning and it gives donald
trump a 29
chance of winning now careful
if you believe this is accurate it is
way too close
to think that anything is remotely
certain in this election 71 to 29
in practical terms is 50 50. now i i
want people to really understand the
math of this
what this means is that if you were to
run a hundred elections with today's
inputs today's inputs in 71
of those hundred elections joe biden
would win
and in 29 of those hundred elections
donald trump would win if nothing
changes
now of course if anything changes
between now and november in the
direction of trump that 29
number goes up but forget about that 29
is really really high i mean just apply
it to your life
does anybody get on a plane if there's a
29 chance
uh of a problem with the plane's uh
flight worthiness of course not
uh does anybody go to a dentist and you
have them
fix a cavity if there's a 29 chance they
make a mistake
you would never go to that dentist more
trivially
i don't take a sip of water if i think
there's a
2.9 chance the water is tainted
never mind 29 so for all intents and
purposes
in terms of our behavior 29 is like 50
50.
and if you need any more convincing
about that
when announcing the forecast nate silver
from 538
actually said coincidentally these are
the
exact same odds as in our final forecast
in 2016 which was clinton's 71 percent
chance to win
trump 29 now if you want to do
you know a little bit of multiplication
the odds of trump winning twice in a row
with 29 percent likelihood is about
eight percent
this is like flipping a coin if you flip
a coin once the odds of heads are 50
if after that first flip you flip it a
second time the odds of heads
on that one flip are still fifty percent
but if in advance i say to you
what are the odds of heads twice in a
row you multiply
point five times point five and you get
twenty five percent
uh similarly if trump's odds really were
29 in 2016 and they're 29 now
in the abstract the odds of winning
twice
with 29 odds are about 8 but it doesn't
matter
it's 29 right now it's essentially a
coin flip
from the standpoint of how we should
behave just vote guys that's it
and uh this reinforces you know when you
see biden plus 12
you might get the impression that we
should be thinking about this
differently it's 50 50. this is a
critical moment
this is not a rehearsal let's not mess
this up
there's something very interesting going
on with noam chomsky
now chomsky's in his 90s and noam
chomsky has for a long time been a
progressive hero to many on the left
until recently when he started saying
things that sound
to be quite frank more like me uh i'm
often called a neoliberal shill by some
on the left who think i'm just not quite
progressive enough and noam chomsky is
suffering a lot of the same fate right
now
recently noam chomsky said it's so
important to remove trump
that every bernie supporter should vote
for biden i agree with that noam chomsky
now agrees
a lot of people uh in a sl in a sliver
of my audience were very mad
about noam chomsky saying that chomsky
was recently interviewed by anand giri
daradas who's been a guest on the show
and chomsky again said things that sound
a lot like me
and some people on the left are now
furious with chomsky now one of the
things i've been saying
is that as a presidential nominee for a
major party
and as a possible president joe biden is
running to the left of just about every
candid candidacy i can think of in the
modern political era
biden is two obamas left on climate and
on health care
and on financial policy and it makes
sense because it's 12 years later the
country
and the democratic party have moved to
the left so it would follow
that biden is to the left of hillary and
to the left of obama and his campaign
indeed is
and i took a bunch of heat from my
viewers for saying that
some people writing in and saying david
that's meaningless to say biden is the
furthest left because
biden might not be sincere in those
policy ideas
and he might not actually get it done
that applies
to any candidate that's an impossible
criticism to address
because you can apply it to any
candidate we'll now known chomsky has
said
almost the same thing who uh said to
anand giridaradas
quote take biden's campaign positions
farther to the left
than any democratic candidate in memory
on things like climate
it's far better than anything that
preceded it
not because biden had a personal
conversion or the dnc
had some great insight but because
they're being hammered on by activists
coming out of the sanders movement and
others
the climate program a two trillion
dollar commitment
to dealing with the extreme threat of
environmental catastrophe
was largely written by the sunrise
movement
and strongly endorsed by the leading
activists on climate change the ones who
managed to get the green new deal
on the legislative agenda that's real
politics
this is a true pragmatic sort
of real politic from noam chomsky and it
actually gets even more pragmatic and
it's fascinating to see chomsky and i
suddenly exactly on the same page
on this issue this next quote is from
the debate over whether biden is good or
merely less bad than trump and
how we should be thinking about that and
anand says to chomsky
this is interesting coming from you your
support for biden is more than merely
grudging
you actually seem to think that the
platform is surprisingly good
given who he is and given with where we
are and chomsky responds quote
this is not support for biden it is
support for the activists
who have been at work constantly
creating the background within the party
in which the shifts took place and who
have followed sanders in actually
entering the campaign and influencing it
support for them
support for real politics the left
position
is you rarely support anyone you vote
against
the worst you keep the pressure and the
activism going
chomsky is pointing out it's not new
that the left is in a position
of supporting the least bad it's common
that the left is choosing between
options that are not ideal
or perfect or great and that that's how
progress works and yet
on the one hand sure systemic change has
to come in order to really improve
society
i'm with you but another four years of
trump pushes
us towards this bizarre neo-fascism that
donald trump has espoused
even more and and it gives us another
four years
of falling behind on climate and on so
many issues and things will get worse
now some people will say
it's the biden types one after another
you know obama
the hillary candidacy now biden that's
what led to trump
in some fundamental sense
everything that happened before today
led to where we are today the outcomes
are a result of everything that has
happened but it is ridiculous to say
it's only because of the democratic
nominees
that we now have trump that's a silly
argument it's indefensible
we also got trump because of
anti-intellectualism
xenophobia racism obama being half black
you know there's this very long list of
factors and there is no evidence that
another
four years of trump in power will
generate the collapse
that some on the left want to see
because they believe it will usher in
some truly left system of government
there's no evidence
that that would happen the last four
years have proven that and
it's very interesting to hear this not
from me although
this sounds like my monologues from four
months ago uh
but from noam chomsky we'll have
continued coverage of this on the david
pakman show
instagram david davidpakmanshow and you
can follow
me on instagram as well at david.pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpackman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
welcome back to the david pakman show
it is great to welcome today dr bandy
x lee to the program who is a yale
university forensic
psychiatrist and uh this is maybe a
field
dr lee that not everybody is familiar
with
can you talk a little bit about forensic
psychiatry and the work that you do
yes a forensic psychiatrist works at the
interface of psychiatry and the law
and so in terms of my clinical work i
mainly work in
prisons or state hospitals where many
legal issues may become
important and we do uh
if evaluations for courts
um such as capacity to stand trial or
criminal responsibility
i do civil cases such as uh asylum cases
and
uh i also have been teaching at yale law
school
for 15 years and so there's a lot of
overlap between the law and psychiatry
so
one of the the general skills and
abilities
seems to be uh evaluating sort of the
uh state the emotional state the the
cognitive state of individuals
often in the context of of criminal
proceedings but also in other contexts
as well
yes so you have grown quite a following
on twitter and elsewhere because of some
of the observations you've made about
the president donald trump
and and you know to to make it totally
transparent to the audience
you're very concerned about the behavior
and the actions of the president
um when when did this first become
something you started paying attention
to
and and started to speak out about it
what was it that you were
seeing from the president you know i was
very distant from any
of the political world and was mainly
working as a clinician
and academic and although i have
consulted with a number of governments
on public policy and
prison reform in particular i had not
considered politics to be a domain for
me to speak about
but the day after donald trump's
presidential election
i was contacted by numerous members from
the public from
civil society members and others who had
known of my work
and so i was inundated with phone calls
and
messages and i
had to think to myself if i have been
working as a violence expert which is
my area within forensic psychiatry and
also
in public health i had been working
to prevent violence at multiple levels
individual
collective societal and would i
turn away from the situation when it
poses
perhaps the greatest level of danger
that we could ever face
and potentially be a trigger for the
greatest amount of
violence in society what were the first
behaviors of donald trump's that
that made you realize that there's that
possibility of danger and violence
well um there are many trigger signs
that we look for in terms of danger and
violence-proneness
and and because
past violence is often an indicator for
potential future violence we look at
things like
verbal aggression history of boasting
about sexual assaults
and inciting violence as he has done
at his rallies um and
uh definitely during the presidency he
has taunted
allies and enemy nations with nuclear
power
um and all these are signs of danger
of course there are also psychological
characteristics that he exhibited
including impulsivity recklessness uh a
need to
constantly burnish a sense of power uh
preoccupation with a grandiose sense of
uh self-image
uh all of these things are associated
with violence and therefore things to
look out for
so inevitably and even in the responses
that you sometimes get on twitter
people will bring up the goldwater rule
the goldwater rule you're not supposed
to diagnose you're not supposed to
assign conditions to people
inc who you have not examined uh in
person
and increasingly i'm reading more and
more about how that was really a a sort
of political convention
more than any kind of um
sort of definitive um uh clinical
consideration and that it it dates back
to barry goldwater and the idea that
there was an effort
made to prevent so-called armchair
diagnosis of what of what were concerns
about about goldwater
before we go further maybe you should
address that in terms of what
what is okay for you to observe and
comment on having not
examined donald trump in person
well first of all the goldwater rule is
unusual
in that it was as you say a political
compromise it was not
it did not derive out of research or
clinical concerns or
professional practice but rather out of
a lawsuit against
a popular newspaper at the time
called fact magazine which had done a
survey
of psychiatrists and it was unusual for
the american psychiatric association
to come up with an ethical
so-called ethical guideline in response
to political situation
but under the trump presidency it has
certainly been
abused it has uh
also been modified about a couple weeks
after
a couple months after donald trump's
inauguration
they modified it to cover not just
diagnosis but
any comment on a public figure of any
kind that actually goes against the
original goldwater rule because the
original goldwater rule was an
affirmative obligation
in that we should participate in
activities that promote public health
and so when we're asked about a public
figure we should
educate the public to improve its health
and well-being
uh just not diagnose because the
diagnosis you cannot do unless you have
all the medical records and
nowadays we do diagnosis not by personal
interview alone
but by external observation and
getting collateral information from
those who have directly interacted with
the person
so uh so one might say that
the rule has also been invalid since
1980
definitively it was considered outdated
since its inception in 1973
but since 1980 our diagnostic practices
have changed in that we don't
just rely on a personal interview so
that having been clarified i'd love to
get your perspective
on the where or if
sort of some different areas of concern
with the president
overlap or where they are separate so
you've already talked about
the sort of personality traits past
glorification of alleged sexual assault
etc you've kind of outlined that
we then have his assertions about the
cognitive test
he has taken and and claims to have
passed that we believe is the montreal
cognitive assessment which includes
identifying a few animals counting
backwards from 100
by seven uh drawing a clock remembering
words etc there's that piece and i'm
curious
if and how that interacts with your
observations so far
and then there's also these
the the the mispronunciation of words
yesterday in fact
uh repeatedly referring to fatalities as
fatalities and having an expression on
his face that he seems to know he's
saying something wrong but unable to
correct it
the oranges of an investigation is
another example where
there was an expression of recognition
that something was wrong but unable to
say oh no i mean the origins of an
investigation
are these three categories related are
they separate
how do they relate if so
so um i
had been listening to donald trump's
interviews about this recent so-called
recent
cognitive test that he's taken and it
turns out it is the test that he took
over two and a half years ago under
white house
dr ronnie jackson yes and um
and you're correct in that it turns out
to be the montreal cognitive assessment
which really is not it's first of all
not
a fitness exam as dr jackson tried to
assert
it was and also it
is not even a good cognitive screen
because um research studies have shown
that
full-blown alzheimer patients and
hospitalized schizophrenia patients
can equally ace the test and so
therefore the alzheimer research
consortium came out
stating that the screen should not
replace
a full neuropsychiatric or
neuropsychological examination when it's
indicated
well for the president it certainly is
indicated because he has shown
not only numerous multiple um
very grave signs of
cognitive impairment as well as decline
over time we have considerable
information on him
because of uh multiple public
appearances over time and
it it shows a pattern of decline
that is recognizable for clinicians in
other words
um uh often people become
concerned about uh joe biden for example
but in comparison uh mr biden's
impairments are
superficial and more recognizable
as non-concerning ones whereas mr
trump's
impairments are are fit the pattern
of very serious um ongoing
cognitive decline that is related to his
own
family history of dementia which he
would be predisposed to because of his
family history
and now i'm not really making a
diagnosis here because i'd like to point
out that
this can indicate multiple possibilities
of uh cognitive decline for um
for one does not simply come about
because
of dementia or other
neurogenerative diseases it can occur
because of
stress because of worsening psychiatric
conditions that he may otherwise have
or it can be a whole host
of other things so that's why we don't
diagnose without having all the medical
records and without doing
a fitting examination even if it doesn't
include
a personal interview we need to do uh
an examination of the data that are that
are appropriate
and so what it does indicate however
is that we are seeing signs of very
serious pathological processes that need
a
thorough examination not a 10-minute
screen like the montreal cognitive
assessment
and i believe that the president has
been
bringing this up himself because he
himself
is concerned about his own mental
fitness
he often brings up topics when he
feels that he needs to fight um
his own notions uh and of course others
as well
that he may not be fit for duty and he
has very valid reasons for concern
but he does this by trying to convince
himself
that he that he is fit and uh
in addition to trying to convince others
and so he
is repeatedly bringing up this test that
he had done two and a half years ago
i think relates to dr ronnie jackson
who was a white house employed
and as a military officer subordinate to
the commander-in-chief
and so he is he would not be in a
position to do a fitness test
he does not have the independence but he
still
used this 10-minute screen to declare
the president
mentally fit in a press conference and
so that in itself is
is a considerable breach of medical
ethics
i don't know whether or not he was aware
of
his um false
declarations but um because
of this episode of his
perhaps administering a test
that really would not tell us very much
but doing so anyhow
was perhaps an attempt to reassure the
president
but above all it uh ended up misleading
the public
when when the public was raising many
questions about the president's fitness
now uh dr jackson has been removed from
his position
about two years ago and amid
other allegations that would make his
medical ethics and standards of practice
questionable
we're going to go to a break on the
podcast tv and radio show but we'll have
our
complete conversation with dr lee on on
our youtube channel
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as one dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay i don't want to spend a ton of time
on this but i want to cover two really
crazy reactions to the biden harris
campaign
uh sort of coming together in the last
24-48 hours that we've seen
the first is remember that wacky
fox news host former judge janine pirro
she sort of suggested last night that
she knows
something about how joe biden is not
actually going to be on the ticket by
november she suggests
something is going to happen to joe
biden between now and november although
she doesn't actually say what let's look
at the clip
well i i have a lot of thoughts the
first thought that i have jesse is
for some reason i just have this feeling
that joe biden isn't going to be on the
ticket
i have a sense that something's going to
happen before
the election and he's not even going to
be on the ticket so don't even ask me if
he's going to make the four years
but let me just tell you a little bit
about what i saw
so immediately the questions start is
this a death threat
is janine pirro trying to subtly suggest
to her audience that someone
do something about joe biden is this
merely
some kind of allusion to a health issue
she believes joe biden's going to have
between now
and november is piro merely drunk again
and unable to cohere during her program
it's not totally clear um the the sort
of most dangerous and sort of insidious
interpretation of this would be the
stochastic terrorism type situation now
she's of course not saying anybody
should do
anything um but the idea of stochastic
terrorism
is that given a large enough audience if
you
plant an idea that something
could be done that
it becomes statistically likely that
you would influence one person to do
something there
the first time that we discussed
stochastic terrorism on this program was
back
in i don't even remember what year when
glenn beck
was ranting and raving about the tides
foundation he had all sorts of ideas and
conspiracy theories about the tides
foundation and it actually led to
a particular guy getting weapons
and was was stopped on the highway i bel
i'm going from memory i believe it was
in california
on his way to attack the tides
foundation and of course
glenn beck would not be held legally
responsible for that if the if the
shooting or bombing or whatever were to
be carried out but
the guy who was on the way said yeah i
watched fox at the time glenn beck was
on fox news i watched watch fox news and
watch glenn beck
and it's it's sort of uh it's a
mathematic it's a statistical thing
where
if 0.01 of an audience is likely to
actually do the violence
that is implied by a host if you have a
hundred people in your audience it's
unlikely to reach the threshold of one
person going and doing something if you
have a thousand people it's unlikely
but once you get to an audience of a
hundred thousand of five hundred
thousand of a million two million
even a small likelihood of influencing
someone
becomes likely to actually influence one
five
ten fifteen people to go and carry out
an
action so that would be like the most
uncharitable
interpretation of what janine pirro is
doing here
what what is unbelievable
is that this is happening on one of the
country's largest three
cable news networks and it's happening
in prime time and at least as far as we
know right now
there's no repercussions for it there's
no blowback whatsoever
from the perspective of fox news now in
terms of whether anybody would really be
able to do anything to joe biden
joe biden has secret service protection
kamala harris does as well now
and secret service is good at their job
in terms of protecting people
and i imagine that joe biden's safety is
is well handled so that would point more
to the idea
um that she's floating of some kind of
health situation for joe biden so that's
number one
in terms of the just wacky reactions to
biden harris
getting a lot of attention in the first
24 to 48 hours after the announcement of
kamala harris joining the campaign
let's now go to number two uh which
uh we we are not now but tomorrow i'm
going to go
to number two which is uh birtherism
birtherism is back it's less urgent so
we we will discuss it tomorrow but
no shortage of that and of course
birtherism with barack obama was hugely
racially tinged
and what a surprise lo and behold kamala
harris whose
father is jamaican and mother is indian
now
being hit by very similar birther like
questions about whether she's eligible
to be vp
or president were she to be in a
position to
replace joe biden and we're going to
discuss that tomorrow
now i i didn't even want to do this
today
but i sort of i sort of have to
because there is a problem
in the progressive community sam cedar
host of the majority report with sam
cedar
and other shows with sam cedar is uh
doubling down on his allegation that
something is wrong
with the growth that our youtube channel
is experiencing now two weeks ago we
reached
900 000 subscribers on our youtube
channel
and i announced a race against the clock
meaning i i wasn't involving anybody
else
i wasn't assailing anyone's character i
wasn't disparaging anybody's work i was
challenging myself and you i was
challenging the audience
can we get to a million youtube
subscribers by election day
at the time i said it we were projected
by socialblade which is a website that
tracks this sort of thing
to get to a million subscribers by
january 9.
we were scheduled to miss election day
thanks to your support over the last two
weeks
the growth curve has accelerated and
instead of january 9th
instead of december we are now scheduled
to get to a million subscribers
on november 23rd which means we're down
to just
20 20 more days that we can move that up
and we will hit a million by election
day
well sam cedar who's also in
this kind of area between 900 000 and a
million subscribers
he seems to think i'm cheating he seems
to think i'm doing something wrong and
he suggested last week that i might be
using
bots or some other kind of a mechanism
elements of cheating for lack of a
better term to get to a million
subscribers
he's fallen a bit behind in the race
okay
and he's now lashing out he's doubling
down on these wild claims he he actually
seems a little bit unhinged
check this out and remember we're just
kidding around this is all in good fun
remember uh that that this you don't
actually have to email me
or him about this but take a look at
what sam said
barrett home too uh great seeing you on
msnbc over the weekend where can i find
the full episode online
so i can send it to my mom also you're
doing an impression of chris hayes your
cadence seem very familiar
i like the old matt on thursdays can you
interview david pakman on one of the
shows
uh we're in a big war right now with
david pakman i know people know that
so no way no way
well what if he gives you views by being
on god you just do this stuff yeah
jiu jitsu well you know with the way
pacman works he just come on to steal
subscribers i know the way that he's
what he's up to so that that's a pretty
low blow
i don't have a history of stealing
anything and by the way this is not zero
sum
you know you can subscribe to his
channel and mine
sam's problem is he's operating in the
paradigm
of a zero-sum world where you're either
subscribed to him or subscribed to me
he thinks if i get a subscriber i've
taken something from him
that's maybe rightfully his or something
like that people can subscribe to both
of us there's no way to steal
subscribers and this diatribe and screed
actually continued
you know with the way pacman works he
just come on to steal subscribers
i know the way that he's what he's up to
can we get into this
right now this is like i wanna i've been
trying to hold off on this
but there's something fishy going on
we're going to do a deep
deep dive into this at one point with
david pakman's subscriber numbers
because you know normally
subscriber numbers go like this all
right
they normally go like this that's the
normal graph
of subscriber numbers okay it's also my
notes to myself here wait a second let
me do this
let me tell you what has happened with
uh david pakman's numbers
they have gone like this something very
fishy is going on
that is not a normal subscriber grab ben
shapiro's way to sabotage you he's like
getting it on there well i don't know
what it is but i will tell you this
i suggested very lightly
very lightly that maybe there were bots
at play
and then all of a sudden i get a bunch
of emails
saying i'm not a bot but they
oh but they all are clearly sent from
bots
look at let's play this yeah look at
that look at what
what's going on there i'm sorry folks
like what is what is that about
there's something going on i think
somebody should investigate this
so this is um i i hate to say it but
this is very trumpian of sam this is a
post hoc post-hoc
rationalization sam is first looking at
subscriber growth on my channel
and then he is after the fact coming up
with an explanation that points to
subterfuge it points to something
untoward
it can't just be hey people are
connecting with the content and they're
subscribing that couldn't possibly be it
it can't be if our growth is faster than
sam's
i must be cheating and this got even
uglier
well do we have a clip of when he uh he
as far as i can tell he got his
subscribers because he attacked me let's
play this clip here
listen um how do we even do this
things are getting really ugly in the
progressive media space
and it pains me to have to do this today
but sam cedar has
casually made a disgusting claim
about the david pakman show and fired
a shot across the bow about our recent
surge of subscribers
claiming absent any evidence mind you
that somehow bots
that i have presumably used or paid for
are boosting our youtube subscriber
numbers
let me give you a little background last
week by the way this is all a joke just
because i know people will
this is all a joke okay last week okay
stop the david pakman
what is he doing there he's trying to
play it off like it's all a joke
that's crazy he's suing him huh this
well i mean i'm i'm not suing him
but i am going to look and see if
there's any type of um
i mean david pakman sitting there
basically calling me a joke
right didn't he just say it's all a joke
i think he's worried that you might go
off the deep end and sue him really like
you never know you could snap any minute
and just
send him a cease and desist shut down
the show better be careful
here's my challenge david pakman okay he
just accused me of being a joke
right like the whole video is about he
just said this is
this is all a joke referring to me and
so
um i as far as i'm concerned that's
uh is that liable or defamation it's
definition right when you say it when
you say it as opposed to libels written
is that right now i i know you guys are
too smart to be goaded into some kind of
conflict here
you all see what's going on i see what's
going on we're not going to fall for it
these bizarre
semantic games philosophical black holes
that people are getting we're just not
going to bite what is his what is what
is his subscriber count at
data experts look into it what is his
subscriber count at it now
at 9 32. 9 32
the guys added like 30 000 subscribers
in like a week
we're down 17 though 15 i thought
we were tied with him two weeks ago
this is bad this is really bad so there
you hear
what this is really about you hear that
in sam's voice right
there is a frustration there that is
being taken out on me
it's being taken out on you as one of my
viewers or listeners
you were called a bot so this we cannot
allow
join the david pakman show youtube
channel
join the pacman to 1 million by election
day 2020 campaign subscribe today it's
free
but in reality let's get multiple shows
uh on the progressive left to a million
subscribers you all know what to do
okay i got a very very important
question via voicemail
this is a practical question about
long voting lines for november take a
listen to this
very important to know the answer hey
david i just have a question
uh is it true that if you are in line to
vote
on voting day or on election day that
you have to legally be allowed to vote
so if the ma
you know even if the line is two miles
long as long as you're standing in it
before the polls close are you legally
able to vote that's
what i'm wondering about thank you okay
very important question legally speaking
if you are in line to vote
by the time the polls close you must be
legally allowed to vote the way it's
supposed to work is
if polls close at eight o'clock at eight
o'clock
someone a poll worker is supposed to go
to the end of the line
and sort of be a placeholder for the end
of the line if you are
in front of the poll worker you must be
allowed to vote
whether it takes five minutes or five
hours or five days because you were in
line while the polls were open that's
the rule you have to get to the polls
before they close
if you try to get in line after the
polls have closed the poll worker would
say
this is the end of the line the polls
are now closed you you you're not going
to be allowed to vote that's the way
it's supposed to work
you can weaponize that you could
hypothetically if you were you know a
bad actor
you could try to disproportionately
send people to try to spread
disinformation
and usher people in line away by saying
the polls have already closed you're not
going to be allowed to vote you could
focus that effort
in democratic precincts for example
where you're not looking specifically at
who's in line but you're like
okay this precinct has more democrats
this precinct has more republicans let's
go to the democratic precinct
and try to get people to go home and say
the polls have closed you're not going
to be allowed to vote you could do that
and so the point is yes if you're in
line before the polls close
you must be allowed to vote there may be
dirty tricks they may pull stuff don't
fall for it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today a florida sheriff is telling his
deputies not to wear masks if you can
imagine
a woman who says she has coronavirus is
being evicted
and we have new polling from the senate
race in massachusetts between incumbent
ed markey and challenger joe kennedy
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist dot com slash
david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video